What's better than a well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well-marbled ribeye you ordered without even leaving the kiddie pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart app and enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Inst. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. Hello, welcome to another Friday Chit Chat.
Hi, we have a fun little guest in the studio with us. So we have Sam, we have Cassie, and then we have Colin who worked with us at Earwolf. Colin, say hi. Hey. Colin's visiting and we have forced him to come in the studio and be on mic with you today. Yeah, I hope being on microphone. I like listening to podcasts, watching podcasts, not talking on podcasts. You're going to do just fine.
Great. Angela, you said you have a share. Well, I do. OK, so a while back, there was an article in The New Yorker, and it was called, Why Do We Still Love the Office? And it had an illustration for the article. It's of everyone in the bullpen. And Jenna, I loved it because right front and center
are Pam and Angela. Angela even has one of her cats. I'm gonna put this in our stories. Do you see that? Yes. Okay, well, I just kind of became obsessed with it because I mean, our two characters are the front two characters and that so rarely happens for us in any kind of artwork
that's done for the office. So I found the artist and his name is Max Dalton and he does a lot of illustrations. And I DMed him on Instagram and I said, is there any way I can get a copy of this drawing? I love it so much. And he was like, absolutely. And he sent me this note.
He said, dear Angela, here's two copies of my illustration of the office. Because I asked if I could have one for you too. Stop it. And he said, as you know, the illustration was made only for an article in The New Yorker. So it's unfortunately quite small. And then he put in parentheses, would
that's what she said apply here? And then he wrote on to say, I hope that's not too disappointing. Thanks to you and Jenna and the rest of the cast for all the hilarious moments. Love, Max. Oh my gosh. Yes, and now you and I each have one. I love that lady that is so sweet. It's so beautiful.
I love his drawing. I just think it captures everything. And you even have prison Mike on the computer screen. So I'll share that in my stories, but I just thought I had to give Max a thank you here on the podcast because that was so wonderful of him. Do you know about the artist that goes to thrift stores and buys paintings and then he like paints people into them? Like he repurposes thrift art. Okay, so he took some thrifted painting of the last supper
and he painted the office into it. So like on the table, there's like a stapler and jello, but then all of our characters are in the painting. And I saw his reel as he was doing it. And I made a comment where I said, oh my gosh, I would love this. This is amazing. And he, I guess, wrote me back and said, you can have it.
But I guess I didn't see his message in time and he ended up selling it. Aw. But his stuff is really cool. It's really fun. This in Nowhere is of the same magnitude of that really cool piece of art passing you by. Yes.
But do you guys remember when I found out that there's a mustard wine by Grey Poupon? Yes. Yes. It's a long time ago and for podcast listeners, well, I guess Grey Poupon reached out to us to send us their mustard wine and I never saw the DM. And you missed it.
And now I can't find it. I don't know where it's like buried in the DMs. Jenna, that guy's name is Tyler Turnbull. Oh, thank you, Sam! Tyler Turnbull Art. Tyler Turnbull. Okay, well, we'll share about him in our stories. Yeah, and I hope Grey Poupon reaches back out to you. Yeah, Grey Poupon, it's not too late. Yeah, come back over.
We'll try your mustard wine. Well, on this same subject, you know, after Lindsay Broad was on our podcast and she talked about true fruit and how much she loves the chocolate covered fruit from true fruit. Yeah. They sent her a whole box of true fruit. That's awesome. She is so delighted. I was texting with her about it. She just texted me a photo of a giant box of true fruit. And I was like, what is happening? And how did this happen? How did this occur?
This is a really hard segue. But as you were saying that, all I could think of is like, there's got to be something, Collin, you can take to help pass your kidney. Oh, no. Oh, no. Some sort of chocolate-covered fruit to help it pass through. That's all I could think of.
I was like, I'm so sorry. We're actually surprised you made it in today. I mean, Jenna and I have been texting you, and you shared with us. And you said it's OK to talk about it. Absolutely. Yeah. You have a kidney stone.
Yeah, we were meant to be meeting Monday, and I called in sick from urgent care. I know. But I sent you an article, Colin, and this is true. Guys, this is not like internet nonsense. Like, this isn't like some reel on the gram. This is a real article where they found that people with kidney stones, if they ride the roller coaster
Big Thunder Mountain Railroad, they pass their kidney stones. Is it something about how it twists and turns? Yes, yes it is. Colin, did you go to Disney Learn yesterday? I didn't. I wondered if I could like claim it back on my healthcare. That seemed like it'd be an excellent like deduction. Yeah, medically speaking you need to go. Yeah, do you have an HSA card? Are you in pain? Yeah, a little bit. I just took some more painkillers. I'm so sorry.
But it seems to come and go. And it's particularly bad overnight, because I'm one of those tornado sleepers that just keeps spinning around. I'm like that, too. And really what I need to do is just lay still. Oh, no. You need to get a cat, and then the cat will sleep on you,
and then you can't turn. Cassie, that's your answer to everything. And that's deductible, right? Yeah. Colin, I pulled up the article. I want everyone to know this information, and I really want to go to Disneyland with you. It says that it has a 70% success rate, but not every rollercoaster works. That
in particular, the Big Thunder Mountain Railroad is the most successful. This group of doctors, they took a 3D model of a hollow kidney containing three kidney stones on the ride in a backpack 20 times. And when they sat in the very last car of the railroad, like you have to sit in the last, don't sit in the front. If you sit in the back, there's a 64% passage rate. If you sit in the front, there's only a 16% success rate. But they expanded their study and they used even more kidney models.
And the second time they did it, when they sat in the back, it was a 70% success rate. They said, in all, we used 174 kidney stones of varying shapes, sizes, and weights to see if each model worked on the same ride. And Big Thunder Mountain Railroad was the only one that worked. They tried Space Mountain
and Aerosmith's Rock and Roller Coaster, but those failed. He said it has something to do with the twists and turns. And he said if you have a kidney stone but are otherwise healthy and meet the requirements of the ride, you should try it. Sounds like a great doctor's day out, right? I know. To convince you at university that you should go to Disneyland.
And just ride this roller coaster how many times? And we'll need to try them all as well just to make sure it works. Also, the Aerosmith one is in Orlando, so they got the budget to fly to Florida to test their experiment. I think they actually only tested this in Florida. So I do wonder Colin. You are s*** out of luck there. I mean, I think Big Thunder Mountain Railroad isn't that the same in Disney World and Disneyland? Unless humidity is a factor.
Colin, we need you to go to Anaheim. Science, science. I have a question that's gonna make me sound really dumb. When you pass a kidney. Stone. Not the whole kidney. Not the whole kidney. When you pass a kidney stone, I knew stone.
I know, I know. When you pass a kidney stone, where does it come out? Your pee hole. You pee it out. Oh God. That's why it's so painful. Where, where does it come out? Your pee hole? You pee it out. Oh, god. That's why it's so painful. Where did you think it came out? I didn't know if you pooped it or peed it.
I wasn't sure. OK. They give you a little sieve to catch it so that they can analyze what caused it. Yeah. So you meant to pee into a sieve for up to a month. Like a sock sieve? Like, what is a sieve?
It's like a coffee filter. Oh, wow. Like if you're panning for gold. Got it. So here you are. It's incredibly painful. You have to pee that out and catch it all at the same time. I have a friend who routinely gets kidney stones.
Oh, no. He's the one who told me about the Big Thunder Mountain Railroad thing. They have a thing where they can go in and zap them, but they'll only zap it if it's a certain size, like if it's too big to pass. And I just want to watch. And one of the ways they go in to zap it is through...
Do they go in through your piano? Oh. So you don't... I wondered, don't you just want to zap it? But I guess maybe you don't. They can also hit it with vibrations from somewhere and break it up that way. It all sounds awful.
I guess you can be genetically predisposed, but also there's some diet stuff that can contribute as well. And we were talking about AI earlier during the break. And so I obviously went straight to AI for, why did I get these kidney stones? What did it say? And well, I just moved into a new place about a month ago with a grapefruit tree.
And I've been juicing grapefruit for breakfast every day for the last month. And AI says grapefruit can cause it. I heard that. My doctor, not convinced by that. Not convinced. OK, your doctor's not convinced by the AI grapefruit diagnosis or the roller coaster cure.
He was more open to the roller coaster. Well, he's called Gary. Gary. Okay, let's call Gary. That's how I've had a Dr. Gary. Gary is the name of a guy that took me on a swamp tour in Louisiana. It's true. I feel like that Gary would be pro Big Thunder Mountain, though.
100%. He agreed that there was exercises you could do and movements or dances that might help shake it out. So he was like, the roller coaster might work in that theory. That or maybe you need to go to a dancer-size class or? Maybe. You can't really picture me at a dancer-sized class, though, right? I sometimes get vertigo, and there's
this maneuver that you can do to reset the crystal in your ear or something. My mom gets horrible vertigo. And we've had to help her drop her head off the back of a bed one time when we were in a hotel at a family reunion and roll her head. Yeah, Lee does it for me. We have this little video that we have saved and it shows him how to you lay your head like you said with coming off the bed and then you like rotate the head in this
certain way and then the crystal goes. I don't know about this crystal but I'm also right now getting acupuncture for my hot flashes and it's's working. And I don't understand that either. I asked the doctor, I'm like, what is it doing exactly? And she said, it's like, it's unblocking your chi. I get acupuncture every month for like the past four or five years. Wow. In that time I've only been sick maybe twice.
So do you just get general acupuncture? Most of the time I'm doing it for my back, because I just like so many people on computers and phones. So yeah, they sometimes do cupping and then they'll just stick like a ton of needles and then my acupuncturist goes, midnight and turns off the lights and leaves for an hour. And you get a little nap. Oh, that's so nice. It's really nice. I can't look at a phone
because I got needles in my back. Yeah. It's, I love it. Yeah. But yeah, I feel like so many people I know, they go into it being like, is this going to work? And then they come out being like, it works. I don't know how, but it's great. I did not think it was going to work. And so if believing in it is part of what makes it work,
then I wasn't not on board, you know, when I went in. So I was fully skeptical. And within two sessions, almost all my hot flashes were gone but I have to keep up with it. I have to go every week. I tried spacing it out and I can go every other but not much longer. But it's like amazing, the amazing relief.
Angela, Sam, this has clearly become the medical episode. Anything you want to talk about? No, no, I'm fine. I'm fully for kidney cells. Um, how's your plantar fasciitis, Angela? A lot better. I got an incline board that I stand on. I put it at the kitchen counter.
It's a little piece of wood. I feel like you could make this if you were handy, but I bought one and I stand on. I put it at the kitchen counter. It's a little piece of wood. I feel like you could make this if you were handy, but I bought one and I stand on it. And it stretches out your entire calf muscle because that's what leads to your plantar fasciitis. And it's got like three settings. You can make it more and more inclined. And now Josh and the kids, we all stand on it.
And kind of one of my favorite things is when people come over and they're like, what's this thing? Because it's right at the edge of the kitchen counter. And I'm like, we all stand on it. And kind of one of my favorite things is when people come over and they're like, what's this thing? Cause it's right at the edge of the kitchen counter. And I'm like, it's an incline board, stand on it. It stretches your calves. And people that stand on it, who clearly haven't stretched their calf in a long time,
they like stand on it and they go like, oh God. And I can now stand on it without like, at least the first setting, right? Like without any pain. So. That's awesome. How are you doing with touching your toes? Oh, pretty good.
Look. This has been a goal of Angela's for a really long time. Hey, she's doing it. Wait, but when you stand up and then bend over and touch your toes, this was your goal. This was like literally your goal this year. She's doing it. You did it, lady.
I did it, yeah. The backs of your legs have just always been really tight. Really tight, I know. I think it's from some of your tennis because you do like these little sprints when you play tennis. Yeah, I also stretch a lot more now before tennis. Yeah.
I do a lot of squats and I do calf stretches and I stretch like my thighs. Yeah, and then, oh, you know what? It's such a great stretch. OK. So I don't know if you guys can do this, but as soon as you start doing it, it gets easier and easier. So what I'm basically just going to do
is go completely into a squat on the ground, and then just sit there and hold it. So it's really good for your quads active stretch for the front of your quads. And your hips. Yes. It's really good for your hips. Yeah, this is, we do this in yoga. I mean, I think I'm going to see what you're about to do.
Okay. She's getting, yep. Oh yeah. That's a yoga pose. It has a name. So I just sit like that. And it's easier when you have shoes on. When you don't have shoes on, it's harder. It's harder without shoes. Yeah.
Oh. Oh, you keep your heels on the ground. Yeah. Your heels have to stay on the ground. I can't do it with my heels on the ground. Yeah. I can do it with my heels on the ground now, barefoot. Nice.
Lady, you had the goal this year as part of your New Year's resolution that you shared with me that it was gonna be the year of touching your toes. Look at you. Look at me go. Look at you go. Look at me go.
You know what my next one is? What? Probably because I've been complaining about my turkey neck. Okay. So my algorithm on my phone knows now. And I constantly get these women of a certain age who are saying, you tired of that turkey neck? It's time to do your mouth stretches. And I signed up.
No, you didn't. This lady said, respond 28 to get my, all my steps. And it's like things like this. It's like, oh, ah, ah, ah. And you do this thing and it's gonna clear up my turkey neck. I cannot believe that you haven't told me this. I did it last night.
I had had a glass of wine. I feel like that's encouraged. Okay. It says I'm gonna reclaim glass of wine. I feel like that's encouraged. OK. It says I'm going to reclaim my jawline. I don't think you are, because I saw these a year ago, and I was like, I'm going to start doing them. Have you been doing it? I did one day of it.
My jaw hurt so bad. That probably means you're activating the muscle. I gave it up. I think what's going to happen is I'm either going to have an amazing jaw line, or I'm going to get a real thick neck. I think you're going to get both. Maybe a thick, tight neck. It's going to be like something like, what's his face?
Like, I'll be back. Yeah. He's got the all neck. What's the one where for photos you're meant to put the tongue on your top of your mouth Like something like, what's his face? Like, I'll be back. Yeah. He's got the all neck. What's the one where for photos you meant to put like the tongue on your top of your mouth and that gives you the jaw line? I don't know which one it is,
but that's like the selfie hack. Oh yeah, I saw that. I saw that. Have you seen the one about like how to get a great photo? Like a great candid photo is where you like, you all link arms and then you sort of like wobble forward. What? And you see all these people doing that online and then you see the photo they got. I want to try that. Is that just because everyone starts giggling? It's like a nice natural smile. Yes, exactly. Well, we have had
people comment that I never look at the camera lens. I don't think you do either. I think Sam and Cassie look at the right dot and you and I look somewhere else. Lady, like when we did our mashup, when we did our thing with PodMeetsWorld and we took a photo, the five of us, a selfie, they are all looking in the camera and you and I are not. And all of the comments are like,
we know who's old in this picture because they're not looking in the camera. And then now like one person commented recently on a post we did Angela, someone commented, dear God teach them how to look at the lens. Oh my God, it's really bothering people. I'm gonna try. You just have to point it out.
The next time we take a picture. We'll take a picture today and we'll do our best with the wobbling forward. Yeah. Colin, you also said there's some thing where you flip your phone around now. Yeah. I mean, I don't know.
It's like the tongue on the mouth thing. I know like half of it from an Instagram post. And it was just younger people saying put it to like 0.5 and flip it around. So you're using the front facing camera of the phone. But you don't know. You don't know if you've got yourself. You can't see if you're in frame front-facing camera of the phone. So you're taking the selfies. You don't know if you've got yourself. You can't see if you're in frame.
You have to have the confidence. That's kind of like old school when we would take selfies with our disposable cameras. Well, I guess it's the better camera on that side, and it gives you the option of different zooms. And then I've seen for the influencers, you can get a little screen that you stick on the other side of your phone.
Oh, so you can see the photo? So you've got a monitor, and you can see like a little screen that you stick on the other side of your phone. Oh, so you can see the photo? So you've got like a monitor and you can see the photo. People are really like, that's a lot. Good at that stuff. But it does look nicer, I think. The light or something. I think it does. The front lens is better than the selfie lens, which is surprising.
You think we take so many selfies, they would design a better lens. What was the first selfie though? Because I feel like we didn't come up with, like I don't remember ever in my youth taking a selfie with a camera. I do. I remember we would turn it around and like just hope for the best. Digital camera. Yeah. But not like film disposable camera. I never like. I did one with a disposable camera. It was too precious. The film, like, yeah. In 1839, Robert Cornelius, a Philadelphia chemist and photography enthusiast took the world's first known photographic selfie.
Wow. Sam, there you have it. Googling like crazy over there. And he just knew that. Yeah, yeah, he just knew it off the dome. All right, well, this has been a very interesting Friday chit-chat, Colin. I might need you back. Yes, please go to Disneyland.
Yeah, we're all going to Disneyland, right? Yeah, we're all going to Disneyland. Yeah, and we're going to pass that stone. I'm sorry you have to pass that out. As a team, we are going to pass it. We are. That's the spirit. Dr. Gary says that's not the bit to worry about.
The pain is like the blockage beforehand. It's like when it's still in your kidney and when it's coming down your internal tubes. Well, I mean, we'll see if he's lying to me. Gary? Dr. Gary. But also, he's like, the kidney stones don't hurt. And it's like, fine if they're just
the nice little round ones. But there's a kind of kidney stone called a staghorn. No. Kidney stone. And it's got prongs? It's got spikes. Yeah. Seems like that'd hurt.
How could it not hurt? Colin, you're just sitting around just in anticipation of excruciating pain. That is such a mind f***. But would this be better on a Disneyland ride? Yeah. I wonder. I want to scream on this ride, Colin.
I can have a little photo memorizing the moment. Yes, exactly. All right, everybody. That was our Friday chit chat. Have a good weekend. Yeah. See ya. Bye. Bye.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.